There's a lot to love about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
It's got action, adventure, and baby Groot!
That's what everyone adores about the MCU,
but there's one thing the sprawling, multi-billion-dollar
movie series hasn't gotten quite right: LGBTQ
community representation.
Many fans have called for Marvel to remedy
this.
The proposed solution?
Simply include more LGBTQ characters in the
MCU!
And according to Marvel Studios president
Kevin Feige, that's exactly what the company
plans to do.
Speaking in an interview with The Playlist,
Feige revealed that Marvel Studios will introduce
at least two LGBTQ characters in the future,
one will be someone fans have never seen on
the big screen before, and another will be
a character viewers are already familiar with.
The executive didn't mince words or skirt
around the topic when it was brought up.
When asked if "a gay, bi, LGBTQ, out character
in the MCU" was in the works, Feige responded:
"Yeah, that's the answer.
[…] Both ones you've seen and ones you haven't
seen."
Though Feige didn't dish up any additional
details, keeping a tight lip on the characters'
identities, it's widely assumed that Tessa
Thompson's Thor: Ragnarok hero Valkyrie is
the LGBTQ character who has already graced
us with her presence.
The actress previously confirmed that Valkyrie
is bisexual, writing on Twitter back in October
of 2017: "She's bi.
And yes, she cares very little about what
men think of her.
What a joy to play!"
"Asgard is danger.
People are dying and we need to get back there,
I need YOUR help."
"Finished.
Bye."
Sadly, only part of that proclamation was
reflected in the final version of the movie.
Valkyrie certainly didn't care about men's
opinions, but the single scene that addressed
her sexuality was cut from the film.
After the devastating events of Avengers:
Infinity War, we aren't sure whether Valkyrie
is actually alive.
Still, fans have their fingers crossed that
she's a-okay and will be out and proud in
an upcoming Marvel movie, especially since
that would reflect the character's modern
day comic book identity.
As for who the brand-new LGBTQ character is
and where they may first appear, the possibilities
are endless.
Will Brie Larson's Carol Danvers have a lady
love in Captain Marvel?
Or could Spider-Man: Far From Home introduce
an LGBTQ teen vigilante like America Chavez
to banter by Spidey's side?
Your guess is as good as ours, but when it
comes down to it, we're just excited that
Marvel is taking any sort of initiative to
make its movie universe more inclusive.
"It's about time."